bonjour à vous bonjour à toutes et à
tous de cette notion se fête son premier
anniversaire
donc merci merci à tous de nous suivre
si vous n'êtes pas abonné abonnez vous
maintenant aujourd'hui on va faire une
foire aux questions et je ne suis pas
tout seul je suis avec christophe je
suis réalisateur au cnrs et sur les
épisodes 2 l d'eau science et
accessoirement accessoiristes je suis
aussi avec stéphane chef opérateur donc
derrière avec la mer à d'habitude et je
fais les montages des as de six ans en
trop et je suis avec nicolas rédacteur
en chef multimédia au cnrs
pour la série s de sciences j'apporte un
peu des d'éditorial quelques blagues
pourries parfois et sinon je travaille
pas mal sur la série plus de science
c'est normal que j'arrive pas à tourner
la tête et nathalie responsables des
médias sociaux au cnrs et j'adore faire
des photos de coulisses et propose des
sciences et je réponds avec léa aux
commentaires que vous postez est là
sinon moi je suis chargé de
communication numérique et pour the
science bon j'ai crié épisode et je les
présente
voilà bon bah c'est parti pour la foire
aux questions alors alors gagny potes et
vivi nous demandent comment est née la
chaîne bah en fait il y avait pas mal
d'image scientifique qui étaient
produites et dans les laboratoires et on
voulait trouver un autre format pour les
valoriser et faire juste des épisodes
des petites vidéos autour de ces belles
images produites dans le cadre d'une
recherche scientifique
regardez ça ressemble à ça
vidéo si c'était d'avoir une présence du
cnrs en tant que vulgarisateur sûr sur
youtube avec un ton décalé par rapport
aux autres contenus qui peuvent être
produits comme les reportages les
documentaires geffroy voilà du contenu
scientifique où on apprend quelque chose
mais où on passe un bon moment on sourit
un peu le point de congélation de l'oea
bello est actuellement franchi et puis
du coup sûr comment est né à chen bin ça
a été le fruit de pas mal de réflexion
on avait fait 1-1 pilotes sur les
ballots mais de ballons qu'on éclate
dans un vieux studio de senna va si mal
vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais un
ballon qu'à éclater de deux façons
différentes
alors mode et le club d'astronomie
d'amnéville nous demandent comment
faites vous pour préparer les épisodes
combien de temps en moyenne faut-il pour
la réalisation d'une vidéo où ça peut
prendre du temps en temps un certain
temps déjà il faut trouver les sujets il
ya plein de façons différentes de
trouver des sujets soient des chercheurs
des chercheuses peuvent nous envoyer des
images
en
et on fait de la veille aussi sur les
actualités de laboratoire il ya des
épisodes qui sont plus compliquées que
d'autres dès qu'il ya des mots de plus
de 3,6 elle l'a très bien compliqué on
choisit un sujet quand il ya des images
qu'on trouve percutante des belles
images par exemple
[Musique]
encore
on contacte le chercheur ou la
chercheuse pour savoir s'il est d'accord
on sait jamais il ya des gens qui
pourraient refuser ça nous est jamais
arrivé il ya des allers retours avec les
les chercheurs une fois qu'on a trouvé
des images pour comprendre déjà donc
leur leur ne resserre ce simple il
s'agit de l'observation au contrat
interférences yale et de sortent ensuite
à passer au à l'écriture ou les a passé
pas mal de temps avec toi
le seul temps fixé à peu près le
tournage où c'est que ça prend un gros
une demi journée
ok
dans pose est ce qui va vraiment faire
évoluer l'épisode en cours de tournage
c'est quand même les blagues donc les
roches
ça c'est cool et ça c'est cool à ce
propos on a une question de le geek et
de quentin
combien d'heures vous faut-il pour
trouver vos blagues oh la la
en tout cas c'est un moment assez sympa
alors on travaille au cnrs et en fait il
ya une super machine dans les locaux
massa générateur de blagues pourries
c'est bon père bon il se peut que la
chute à trouver on est là
il faut savoir c'est que quand on valide
le script souvent la blague de faim et
c'est une suggestion et en la valide au
moment du tournage en fait plusieurs
tests au moment du tournage il faut
toujours tout toujours finir par une
blague pourrez toujours finir par une
blague pourrie et puis alors qui est le
pourvoyeur de blagues en fait un besoin
moi de mon point de vu arriver un moment
donné on a tellement fusée a tellement
fusé de tous les côtés que je sais plus
trop qui a eu l'idée une question de
cesser combien avez vous de sujets en
attente
ah bon on a toujours beaucoup de sujets
sous le coude ou alors allons nous
parler de mathématiques
ouais ouais ouais c'est c'est dans les
tuyaux
[Applaudissements]
donc on a une question de hydroxyque le
ride qui demandent si la chaîne tend à
se développer vers de nouveaux formats
oui on a commencé à faire évoluer la
chaîne vert avec les antilles toutes nos
salutations cherche on a été puisé dans
les archives de sénart à l'image et en a
retrouvé les écorces de recherche
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de ba de changer de forme
un d'avoir plus de formats on nous avait
demandé des formats plus longs des
épisodes plus long qui vont peut-être
plus en profondeur
avec plus de 6 ans on peut croiser un
peu différents aspects pour inférences
disciplines scientifiques
aujourd'hui nous parlons de métrologie
c'est l'étude du match à poser des
questions un peu moins scientifique et
montrer que la science peut s'y
intéresser de différentes façons ça va
rester scientifique est un peu un peu
drôle ou pas on va faire évoluer aussi
la série the science avec des épisodes
hors studio quoi on a utilisé les images
pour rester là on a envie de vous faire
découvrir aussi comment sont produites
ces images discuter avec les chercheurs
genre les hors les murs de 2,16 de
science du studio alexis mutants à une
question
un nouveau featuring de jean claude van
damme est il prévu et bien dès qu'il est
dispo oui oui non il a également des
questions qui reviennent régulièrement
comment avez vous fait votre générique
on a monté un petit studio de stop
motion
c'était ici ça nous a pris 7 heures
voilà donc on remercie sophie qui nous a
aidé à créer ça alors est-ce que vous
tournez sur fond vert
donc si vous n'avez pas trouvé la
réponse à cette question en regardant la
faq c'est qu'il ya un problème mais
comme vous pouvez le voir
alors soit on à fauvergue on est super
fort soit on n'a pas de fauvergue mais
on est quand même ces personnes
[Applaudissements]
donc non ce n'est pas un fonds vert par
contre on peut expliquer un peu oui
donc on a installé ce petit studio que
vous connaissez si bien dans les anciens
locaux de sénas images dans l'ancien
bureau de l'église christophe et donc
avant que ce soit les locaux de ses
nerfs à ces images c'était une station
d'essai donc voilà station d'essai des
moteurs à combustion de l'office
national des recherches scientifiques et
industrielles et des inventions qu'on
appelle un autre nous l'office des
inventions contrariété le prédécesseur
de crs avant 1935 voilà cet épisode très
terre-à-terre est terminé merci raquin à
toutes et à tous de nous suivre
on a regardé les mouches voler bas
rester là continuez à nous suivre et
puis avant de partir je vous sers une
dernière petite goutte
[Musique]